as possible treatments begin to
materialize for coronavirus president
Trump considers plans for reopening
Nancy Pelosi holds up aid for small
businesses while posing in front of a
very very expensive refrigerator and
China admits it fudged the numbers I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn stop putting your online data
at risk get protected it expressive VPN
calm and /ban how many times I have to
tell you expressvpn
dot-com / Ben alrighty well I promise
that was the last Passover day that's it
we're done there's no more pass oh there
are all the people who are emailing
saying where are you
Passover is eight days along at least
outside of Israel we're done okay so
there are no more Jewish holidays for
another forty nine days right not until
she votes oh you have at least a month
and a half until we get to another set
of Jewish holidays so nothing but
Shapiro II goodness from now until then
so we bring you your latest a corona
virus updates obviously because it is
the only thing happening in the news one
of the more odd things about doing the
show during this period in time is
there's only one thing happening in the
news literally no other things happening
in the news so let's jump into what is
happening in the news so yesterday was a
really bad day in the United States for
a number of deaths apparently over 4,500
deaths recorded in the United States now
how many of those deaths were a result
of the change CDC standards in terms of
what counts as at cover 19 death I'm
actually not sure it doesn't really
matter because the bottom line is that
those deaths are attributable to kovat
19 according to the Washington Post
Kovan 19 deaths of snowballed from a few
isolated cases of thousands across the
country each day the US Surgeon General
warrant last week that it would be like
Pearl Harbor turned out to be more than
five times as many Americans died from
Kovan 19 last week than were killed at
Pearl Harbor if you look at a single
week what you see is that kovat 19 was
just on the verge of overtaking heart
disease is the number one killer across
the country in the last week over 19
killed more people from April 6th April
12th than any other cause of death
except heart disease does normally in a
typical April week normally cancer kills
about 11,000 people per week and heart
disease kills about 13,000 people per
week Ovid killed about twelve thousand
four hundred people the week April sixth
to April twelfth so that is really
really scary one of the things that is
scary about that obviously is that if
you prorated that over the course of the
year you are talking hundreds of
thousands of deaths I mean easily
hundreds of thousands of deaths now the
good news is that that is likely to be
the peak when we were likely to see is a
decline in the number of deaths being
reported from around the country the
number of deaths trail the number of
hospitalized cases the number of
hospitalized cases did peak a
you days ago now with that said there's
a lot of talk about when all of this is
going to be reopened how all of this
looks I think it's important when we
talk about coronavirus deaths because
they've all you sees the raw numbers and
very often people will show you a chart
that is one of the more useless charts
that I've seen which is cumulative
deaths and when you look at cumulative
deaths
it looks exponential right the line
looks exponential ikz rising rapidly the
problem with using cumulative deaths is
it doesn't actually tell you whether the
rate of death is increasing whether the
rate of hospitalization is increasing
and that's what we really care about
because if you are just adding the
number of deaths today on top of the
number of deaths yesterday
every time you add three or four deaths
the line continues to go up whereas if
you lost five people yesterday in one
person today on the cumulative on the
cumulative chart that looks like a
continued increase on a non cumulative
chart like on a day-by-day level it
looks like a pretty significant decrease
also important to recognize as I've been
talking about all week
it is deeply irresponsible of the media
to tranch people or fail to tranch
people in the ways that they do what I
mean by that is that if you are looking
at the actual danger of coronavirus you
do have to look at the type of person
who is acquiring coronavirus to pretend
that all people who acquire coronavirus
are equally likely to be killed by
coronavirus or to end up on a ventilator
is simply not true
and it's really irresponsible especially
because when you're talking about
reopening the country you are going to
have to transfer people you are gonna
have to determine who is most vulnerable
and who is less vulnerable and to
pretend otherwise is really silly and
you hear this kind of stuff from members
of the media fairly regularly hear from
members of government all the time
they'll say sure it's more dangerous for
older people but it could kill anybody
well cancer is mostly dangerous to old
people yeah it could kill anybody but
your chances of acquiring cancer at age
30 are very different from your chances
of acquiring cancer at age 75 or age 80
and to pretend that the risk is
equivalent and therefore that the
behavior should be equivalent is
irresponsible and it's blanket
one-size-fits-all policy and we'll get
to more of that when we talk about the
White House policy that's being put
forward and what exactly is going to be
a sort of well realized in rational
policy and and what is not because I
think that there continues to be a
failure to understand the nature of the
virus that is resulting in over-broad
policies when it comes to lock downs and
shutdowns we're gonna get to more of
this in just one second we go through
more of the statistics first let's talk
about the fact you're doing more online
shop
now than ever because you have to I mean
literally all the things are closed you
can get in your car today and drive
around everything will be closed so you
go back home you get online you're like
oh why don't I just shop online except
that everything's a little too expensive
well why don't you use honey right now
it's a free tool that's going to save
you all sorts of money it saved me
probably thousands of dollars at this
point we are all shopping online a lot
honey is the free online shopping tool
that saves you money online
honey automatically finds the best promo
codes and then applies that into your
cart which makes an online shopping
finally feel as easy as it's supposed to
be honey has found it's over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings so you can shop at your favorite
sites like Target Best Buy sephora's
Macy's eBay Etsy well like I use it on
on a huge number of sites Amazon when
you check out the little box drops down
all you have to do is click apply
coupons you wait a few seconds for it to
scan every promo code on the internet
like all of them and then the price just
dropped again I've saved probably
thousands of dollars on house hood bow
household goods and essentials from
Amazon and from Walmart simply by using
honey not using honey you're passing up
free money it's free to use it installs
in seconds and it's backed by PayPal so
you know that it's good get honey for
free at join honey calm slash pen that
is join honey calm / pen go check them
out right now okay so as I say to
pretend that all populations are
equivalently vulnerable to kovin 19 is
deeply irresponsible so I'm gonna give
you the deaths involving coronavirus by
age group in the United States by age
group in the United States over the
course of the over the course of the
last few months basically from February
1st to April 11th hey this is by age in
the United States under one year of age
there have been zero deaths from Kovan
19 from 1 to 4 years of age there have
been two deaths from kovat 19 this is
corny the CDC from five to 14 years
there has been one death from kovat 19
from 15 to 24 years there have been 13
deaths from Kovan 1913 total across the
United States okay but by the way here
is the comparable statistic as to the
number of deaths from all causes during
that period over 5,000 people aged 15 to
24 have died in the period February 1st
to April 11th in the United States 13
from Kovach 19 so obviously this is not
equivalently hitting people when they
say well it's hitting young people too
yeah but not not really I mean
statistically speaking it's really not
hitting young
people particularly hard 25 to 30 for
113 deaths total from February 1st to
April 11th that's out of 11,000 total
deaths during that period 11,000 total
that's 113 from kovat 35 to 44 there
have been nearly 16,000 total deaths
February 1st to April 11th 289 deaths
from covin okay so basically if you're
under 45 years of age the chances that
you are going to die from Kovac are
exceedingly low very very very low even
compared to the number of deaths total
that these groups are experiencing over
this period of time it starts to elevate
as you get older 45 to 54 751 people
have died from kovat 19 out of 30 out of
30 thousand five hundred cases right so
750 out of 750 out of 30,000 cases
that's starting to look like a little
bit more of a percentage now you're
talking about 2% of all deaths in that
age group due to kovat 19 things about -
yeah that's right it's 2% 2.5% of all
deaths in that age group
due to Kovan 19 then it starts to
elevate again 55 to 64 but as you see so
did the number of total deaths right so
55 to 64 1770 three deaths February 1st
to April 11th out of 74,000 deaths so
1800 out of 74,000 so now you're talking
about again about 2.4 percent of all
deaths in that age range are happening
due to Co vyd 19 you guess 65 to 74 2900
deaths out of a hundred and fourteen
thousand total deaths so now you're
talking about again 2,900 deaths out of
114 115 thousand total deaths I'm doing
the math in real time here you're
looking again at about 2.5 percent of
all deaths in that age range are at
makovan 19 so basically if you are below
if you're between the ages of 45 and 74
you are looking at about at 2.5% chance
if you died that you died of kovat 19 so
in other words as more deaths occur in
the group more people are dying from
kovat 19 on an absolute level but on a
percentage basis it's basically the same
from the time you hit 45 it's about time
you hit 74 why because pre-existing
conditions start to kick in a lot more
pre-existing conditions as you get older
and that continues to maintain and grow
as people get older and older right 75
to 80 four years old again these are
statistics from
CDC from February 1st to April 11th 3576
deaths out of 144,000 total deaths so
3576 deaths out of 144,000 total deaths
and you're looking at a rate of again
2.5 percent so it's basically even a
number of deaths then the percentage of
deaths out of total number of deaths
it's just that there are a lot more
older people who are dying so this this
thing is more dangerous for older people
clearly right okay I'm just reading you
the CDC to the CDC statistics and you
can look at these statistics cross
countries okay it is it a hundred
percent true that younger people are
just not suffering from this thing the
way older people are and people who do
not have pre-existing conditions are not
suffering from this thing the way that
older people are and that's really
important right it's really really
important to mention that because
because if you do not mention that then
it doesn't you can't formulate a solid
policy treating people who are 70 and up
or 60 and up or pre-existing conditions
the same way they are treating young
healthy people when it comes to public
policy is really really foolish right
the like and it's and when people hear
so Vox has a piece on this and here's
how they conclude and I think this is
sort of irresponsible they say there's
no need to belabor the point one thing
most people know about Kovan 19 is it
hurts older people the most the data
bear this out people in this age group
are the most likely to be hospitalized
and to ultimately die during the
pandemic for the rest of us the risk is
less severe but far from zero and every
person should be mindful of how their
current health might make them more
susceptible when they say less severe
but far from zero that makes it sound as
though it's sort of my a mile difference
in degree it is a major to Princeton
degree whether you are under the age of
30 or whether you are above the age of
70 these are serious serious concerns
and this is not suggesting that life
itself is more Vaughn is more valuable
at a particular age it's saying if
you're going to tell somebody to go back
to work and all you know about them is
their a 30 year old without pre-existing
conditions or a 70 year old with
pre-existing conditions it makes it a
pretty easy a pretty easy calculation ok
beyond that when we are talking about
how we get people back to work we still
have not found out I mean it's
unbelievable to me we've not done this
we still have not done random antibody
testing in the United States to find out
how many people have actually had this
disease that makes a huge difference
because if it turns out that the rates
are one tenth of what we have been told
right if the rates actually are not five
or six percent they are 0.6 or 0.5% that
changes
matically especially because for younger
and not as vulnerable people the rates
are going to look more like the seasonal
flu like 0.1% for people who are young
and healthy now again that doesn't mean
that this is the flu because the 0.1%
death rate for the flu includes people
who are older and vulnerable and people
have had vaccine and people who are out
there in public doing all these sorts of
things with that said to pretend that
all age groups and all health groups are
equally vulnerable to this thing as the
government keeps saying because the
government won't just tell you the truth
here's an immediate members won't either
here is the truth if you are young and
you're healthy your chance of dying from
this thing are near zero okay if you are
young and healthy your chances of dying
from this thing are very very close to
zero because first even if you have to
acquire it which many people will not
acquire it even if you do acquire it
according to the New York City health
data if you are young and you are and
you are in your own pre-existing
conditions the number of people who have
died in New York City right which is the
epicenter of this thing poor young and
and and healthy is minut I mean I the
like I looked at this data just before
the holiday and the New York City health
data on kovat 19 is pretty clear about
this if you look at that if you look at
the rates of death by age if you look at
the the Cova nineteen probable kovat 19
deaths so now I'm looking at the the PDF
that is that is last updated as of April
15th the total number of people under
the age of 45 in New York City right
which is experienced now what seven
seven eight thousand deaths total right
the city of New York number of people no
underlying conditions under age of 45
live died 29 29 out of that grand total
of number of people who died hey gran
number total the people under 65 who
have died with no underlying conditions
would be twenty nine plus seven plus
sixty seven so 96 okay that is it that
is not a huge number
the reason that I'm saying this is
because when you make plans for who goes
back to work you need to know these
numbers beyond that beyond that
everybody is suggesting that they know
the Cova 19 fatality right two things
can be true one Kovan 19 spreads
extremely easily right by all available
data it spreads extremely easily also
the death rates are not nearly what the
WHI begs them at it like 3.4 percent I
have evidence of this that I will bring
you again in one second it's starting to
be
consistent across sort of various
different studies I'll bring you a study
from the Netherlands that really
suggests that this thing does not have
the these sort of deadliness that people
are suggesting it has absolute
deadliness because if a ton of people
acquire a virus and it has a low
percentage of killing people still a lot
of people die from the virus but the
absolute death rate of this thing is not
is not as high as the wh all originally
made it out to be or any of the death
rates that you're actually seeing in the
media I'll give you the evidence of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you are using ear
buds on a regular basis now right you're
at home you got to have noise canceling
you're on a conference call you're
listening to podcasts you're watching
Netflix on your phone and whatever it is
you need a good pair of ear buds it's
not going to cost you a fortune because
who has money to waste these days what
you need are the everyday e25 ear buds
from Ray Khan they're the best ones yet
six hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass a more compact design
that gives you that nice noise isolating
fit ray cons wireless earbuds are
incredibly comfortable
they're perfect for conference calls
video chats binging podcasts unlike some
of your other wireless options ray con
earbuds are stylish and discreet no
dangling wires no stems order rake on
your buds right now while they are still
in stock now is the time to get the
latest in the best from Ray con get 15%
off your order at buy Raycom /ban one of
the things I like about my retcons aside
from the fact you can get them in a
variety of colors is they really fit
your ear they're not one-size-fits-all
they send you this metal card it has
some rubber pieces on it that you can
actually pop onto the earbud so
perfectly fits your ear get them at by
rekha Netcom / been 15% off ray con
wireless earbuds that's by rake on
Comstock Ben again Bui are a YCL when
comm /ban by rake on comm / ben go check
them out right now okay so as i say we
still don't know the true case fatality
rate and this is what I've been focused
on for weeks here how has it been weeks
and we still don't have antibody tests
why has it been left to private
entrepreneurs and universities like
Stanford to do this testing how is it
the CDC has not done random antibody
testing in hot spots in the United
States to determine how many people
actually have this thing so last week or
actually earlier this week I reported to
you that there was a study that was done
in New York where something like 215
pregnant women came in and 14 percent of
them had kovat 19 but only 1.9 percent
of them actually had symptoms of Kovan
19 which suggests that the vast majority
of people who had kovin 19 or have kovin
19 are asymptomatic
means is that the denominator in your
case fatality rate even in New York City
is really really high like a lot higher
than it has been made out to be and now
we have another proof of this according
to one study the head of Netherlands
National Institute for Health is an
imaging shop on zazul announced on
Thursday that three percent of all
people in the Netherlands have the
antibody for kovat 19k three percent
which is really high as henslowe I will
tell you why that is really actually
quite high so the Netherlands as of last
night
had twenty eight thousand three hundred
eighty-three diagnosed cases in the
Netherlands with three thousand three
hundred twenty seven deaths that would
mean about an 11 percent case fatality
rate right really high basically you get
this thing you are in serious trouble in
the Netherlands however that antibody
test shows that three percent of the
population of the Netherlands actually
already has the antibody which means
they've already had this thing that
means 518 thousand four hundred cases of
coronavirus based on their population
they're about 18 million people who live
in the Netherlands so instead of twenty
nine thousand diagnosed cases are twenty
eight thousand diagnosed cases you are
talking about an order of magnitude time
and then multiply that by to the number
of people who actually have this thing
so twenty times the number of people
have had this thing as as the actual
reported cases are so that means that
their case fatality rate in terms of
death over a number of people who have
actually had this thing is not 11
percent it's poor at 0.6 percent it's
0.6 percent it takes it down by a full
level of magnitude and then divide that
by two right takes it down by a factor
of 20 right as you increase the
denominator by 20 and you are decreasing
the death rate by a factor of 20 and by
the way again worthy of note that in the
Netherlands the case fatality rate by
age is wildly disparate okay I'm looking
at these this is from statistic aam
looking at the case fatality rate the
case fatality rate in the Netherlands
which allegedly has an 11 percent case
fatality rate according to the Johns
Hopkins coronavirus data for everyone
under the age of 24 there is a zero
percent case fatality rate 25 to 29
point one thirty to thirty four point
one thirty five to thirty nine point one
forty to forty four point one forty five
to forty nine point two then just like
in the United States it starts to
elevate once you hit 50 right then in
0.9 1.5 two point nine for people who
are
over the age of between 60 and 64 6.44
65 to 69 and then it starts to really
elevate to the point where if you are 80
to 84 years old there's a 22.4% case
fatality rate what does this suggest it
suggests that it's idiotic to treat
people who are young and healthy like
people who are older when you are trying
to come out of this thing it just makes
no sense
beyond that there is some serious
question about exactly how you're going
to test for this thing so as we will see
everybody is saying fast testing best
testing regimens big testing temperature
check so we can go in first of all
temperature checks ain't gonna do crap
temperature checks are completely
useless in my opinion the reason I say
that they are completely useless is
because Scot Gottlieb right the former
FDA Commissioner who's very big on
testing Scot Gottlieb quoted a study
yesterday quote new study shows that
people with Cova 19 may be most
infectious before symptoms develop so
what the hell does a temperature check
do I can check you for a temperature
you're asymptomatic doesn't matter you
just infected the entire office so what
exactly does a temperature check
accomplish the answer is nothing so if
the CDC is recommending temperature
checks that's pretty much useless so
then the question is how many antibody
tests can be done how quickly and then
the antibody right I assume is going to
take you know a day or two for your body
to manufacture in the antibody but even
if that's not the case
how exact are all of these coronavirus
tests you know we've been relying on
these tests question what is the failure
rate on the coronavirus tests if you had
coronavirus tests all across the United
States does that pick up everybody
because here's the problem all you need
is one person who's a super spreader to
started spreading in a community again
now corn virus testing could be useful
if it were really really widespread and
identifying hotspots and then presumably
you could do some contact tracing but if
this thing is so widespread that three
percent of the population of the
Netherlands already had it and they've
been in lockdown then it's gonna be very
difficult when people are asymptomatic
to determine exactly how you lock this
thing down the best you can hope for is
to lock down some of the hot spots but
you're never gonna be able to completely
remove it from the population and that's
why we have to be super accurate about
what it is that we were attempting to do
with the lockdown in the first place and
what things are gonna look like when the
lockdown ends what things are gonna look
like when the lockdown ends is if you
have a pre-existing condition or you're
elderly you really shouldn't be going
out in public
truly like I would tell my grandparents
this room a both my grandparents are
nursing homes well about both my
grandmother's I would not be like oh
yeah go bed
the grocery store even with the mask on
it's just too risky there's no reason
for you to do it but for me and my wife
and my kids you know there's really no
reason for us not to go out now the
question becomes whether we should
socially distance okay the only reason
to socially distance is because I have
parents who are 64 I would prefer not to
pass it on to my parents but as far as
me acquiring it or my wife acquiring it
or my kids acquiring it there's not
significant risk to them of death that
is tremendously in excess of other risks
that you go about on a daily basis that
doesn't mean go and have like
coronavirus parties or something where
you're infecting anybody else but to be
accurate about the risks we ought to be
accurate about the risks we don't want
community spread
we don't want infecting people who may
have pre-existing conditions and are
vulnerable and who are not staying
indoors but again as we will see a lot
of measures that are now being attempted
I'm not sure are actually going to be
completely effective right I have
serious questions about how this testing
regimen that people are talking about is
actually going to be implemented on a
practical level and whether in fact we
ought to be pursuing a policy that
basically says to people if you are
young and you're healthy go back to work
wear a mask
socially distance oh you're not
increasing the risk of transmitting this
to people who actually are vulnerable
and that's about all we can do at least
until there are better treatments that
are come up with now in a second I'm
gonna tell you there are some treatments
that are being come up with that could
radically change the game and that is
really really good news there are some
treatments that hospitals are now using
remember people keep saying vaccine
vaccine vaccine if a really good
treatment comes along that mitigates the
risk of coronavirus then the vaccine is
still really useful but it doesn't
become quite as urgent or it's not like
we have to lock down until there's a
vaccine if there's a treatment available
that mitigates the effects of Kovan 19
such that the risk of death goes down
dramatically we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that more than ever with this level
of economic uncertainty you know you
need to know your business down to the
nitty-gritty and when the economy opens
back up and when you are ready to go you
need your business to be ready and
raring to go on every level it needs to
be efficient it needs to be absolutely
hard tax data-driven this is why you
need NetSuite by Oracle the world's
number one cloud business system with
NetSuite we give you financials cash
flow payroll inventory and more all in
one place to have clear visibility and
total control of your business NetSuite
customers have the flexibility to work
from anywhere with immediate clarity on
critical information directly at their
fingertips
no more guessing no more waiting make
smarter decisions with confidence
because
you got crystal clear visibility into
your numbers join over 20,000 custom
companies who trust NetSuite to stay in
control and right now is a terrible time
to blindly stumble through your business
the fact is you need to be on top of
your data at all times we here are at
the daily where you should be to receive
your FREE guide managing business
uncertainty and schedule your free
products will right now at NetSuite calm
/ appear oh don't wait to get that free
guide schedule your free product tour at
NetSuite calm / Shapiro's that is
NetSuite calm / appear oh go check them
out right now okay so as I say as
treatments come up that is also going to
suggest that we ought to be opening up
at society more right if we can lower
the death rate fairly dramatically then
of course we ought to be opening society
up more on a concomitant basis so a
couple of good pieces of news CNN is
reporting that patients are now being
turned over on their stomach in the ICU
or in the hospital and that that is
actually a pretty effective effective
treatment for getting people oxygen to
their lungs according to CNN doctors are
finding the placing the sickest
coronavirus patients on their stomachs
called prone positioning helps to
increase the amount of oxygen getting to
their lungs a doctor named Mangala
Narasimha Han who works at the Long
Island Jewish Hospital said we're saving
lives with this 100% said it's such a
simple thing to do we've seen remarkable
improvement we can see it for every
single patient dr. Catherine Heather
director of medical ICU at Massachusetts
General Hospital says once you see at
work you want into it more and you see
it work almost immediately so that is a
good piece of data now ventilated
patients require sedation when they are
paced placed on their stomach which
could be a longer stay in the ICU for
example and it might be uncomfortable
for a non sedated patient spend 16 hours
on their stomach but people are
definitely giving it a try and even more
optimistic news there was an early peek
of data on a Gilead coronavirus drug now
we've heard about this one before right
the stroke is called REMS a severe
you've heard president Trump talk about
it at some of the press conferences this
was originally I believe in HIV AIDS
drug REM the severe okay and it was one
of the first medicines identified as
having the potential to impact kovat 19
according to stat news.com the entire
world has been waiting for results from
Gilead clinical trials the University of
Chicago Medicine recruited 125 people
with Cova 19 into Gilead to Phase three
trials of those people 113 had severe
disease all the patients were treated
with daily infusions of REM to severe
the results of not yet been released but
there was a tape of a of a University of
Chicago infectious disease specialist
talking about this study
Anna leaked her name is kathleen Mullane
she said the best news is that most of
our patients have already been
discharged which is great we've had only
two patients perish the discussion was
recorded stat obtain a copy of the video
the outcomes offer only a snapshot of
REM - suvir's effectiveness the same
trials are being concurrently run at
other institutions as impossible to
determine the full study results with
any certainty still no other clinical
data from the Gilead studies have been
released to date excitement is high
Gilead said in a statement on Thursday
what we can say at this stage that we
too look forward to data from ongoing
studies becoming available which is
basically they have there they're not
gonna release the information as of yet
one of the reasons that people don't
release preliminary information is
because it creates hold ups with things
like the New England Journal of Medicine
melanne said when we start the drug we
see fever curves falling she says fever
is not now a requirement for people to
go on trial we do see when patients come
in with high fevers they do reduce quite
quickly we have seen people come off
ventilators a day after starting therapy
so overall our patients have done well
most of our patients are severe most of
them are leaving at 6 days so that tells
us duration of therapy doesn't have 10
days the University of Chicago Medicine
said that drawing conclusions at this
point is premature and scientifically
unsound that's not stopping people from
of course being being deeply optimistic
about this which again I don't think
it's a problem I think being optimistic
about things is okay you just have to
recognize that there's an inherence
amount of uncertainty when these studies
have not yet been fully vetted meanwhile
as I say we're gonna have to get used to
the idea that a vaccine may be a ways
off and that a vaccine it may not even
work because the virus is mutating the
question is whether it's mutating in
such a way that it makes the disease not
not very not vaccine vulnerable that
vaccines only work on diseases where the
disease does not change in a certain way
particularly fast so measles right it
changes but it doesn't change in such a
way that the vaccine won't work on it
flu changes and it changes in such a way
the vaccine only works on certain
strains of the flu so one of the
questions is whether corona virus is
going to be vulnerable to vaccines or
not according to the New York Times it's
unclear how mutations in the genome will
ultimately affect countermeasures
a vaccine so we may have to get used to
the idea that a vaccine is a little ways
away and as I mentioned before people
are most transmissive when they are
asymptomatic so with all of that said we
can see that there's a tremendous amount
of uncertainty and we are going to have
to steer into the uncertainty there is
no certainty here there is no world
where the cases go down to zero there is
no world where everything is hunky-dory
and then we just and then we just all go
back to normal
we are going to have to accept a certain
level of raised risk in our lives for
any level of lockdown to come to an end
and you can see that really most not
even in the United States you can see it
most in places like Singapore I Germany
is beginning to gradually reopen their
economy next week they had locked down
in January Singapore has reopened and
Singapore saw a new daily high of 728
cases yesterday so a second wave is
likely to happen this is why when people
were ripping on Sweden for having a more
open society and they're saying we'll
look they've had an increased risk of
people dying and getting infected right
because their societies more open that
is just what is going to happen you're
not gonna know whether Sweden made the
right call for a year right one year
from now if you come back and Sweden has
had way more deaths on a per capita
basis than other countries around it
then you're gonna say Sweden made the
wrong call but if Sweden ends up about
the same as the other countries around
it or in the ballpark and they didn't
shut down their economy everybody's
gonna be asking whether Sweden had this
thing right from the beginning and
whether deep scale lock downs were
actually the correct solution from the
very beginning again Singapore is seeing
a second wave and this is what I've been
complaining about for a while is that
people are not being honest about what
the second wave looks like I've been
saying this for weeks I've said all the
studies that were being cited did not
take into account a second wave that
University of Washington's study people
when they said lockdown lockdown
lockdown the question was what happens
the minute we stop locking down aren't
we just gonna go out and reinfect one
another and the fact is we do need to
get out there we do need to change we do
need to change the direction of the
economy 22 million Americans have filed
for unemployment in the past four weeks
it's one in four weeks that is the
fastest spike in unemployment in
American history and it is not close it
is not close the charts are absolutely
stunning initial jobless claims per week
when it got really bad in 2008-2009 you
were saying about half a million initial
jobless claims per week I like the very
beginning of 2009 we saw 22 million
in four weeks in the United States this
cannot go on it cannot go on this way it
just can't we're gonna get to that in
just one second and then we're gonna get
to president Trump's plan to reopen
because let's be real about this also
Democrats right now are holding hostage
more small business funds so at the same
time that they are suggesting that
lockdowns continue and again and say
it's a bipartisan thing there's some
people who want lockdowns to continue
some people who want lockdowns
alleviated but a long sort of grassroots
partisan lines Democrats largely want to
see the lockdowns continue and
Republicans largely want to see the
lockdowns come to an end ASAP hey with
all of that said and again it's not a
completely partisan issue but it does
seem to be in sort of public opinion
polling breaking down along partisan
lines for the Democrats to be holding up
small business aid at this point which
is the only thing keeping people's
income afloat is really insane and Nancy
Pelosi was doing some of that yesterday
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that has
literally been no better time not to go
to the post office like ever in human
history you're going there and you're in
line and you're handling packages you
don't know how long all this stuff lasts
I'm packing like now is a great time not
to go to the post office right you're at
home anyway
you can't really go to the post office
it's not really a luxury that most
people are willing to undertake why not
do all of this from home this is where
stamps.com comes in here at daly where
we've used stamps calm since 2017 we've
been saving ourselves time and we've
been saving ourselves at money stamps
calm brings the services of the US
Postal Service directly to your computer
and the safety and comfort of your own
home office anywhere else who are
hunkering down right now whether you're
a small business sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
you're just working from home and you
need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package and in class of mail
anywhere you want to send it and once
your mail is ready you leave it for your
mail carrier you schedule a free package
pickup you drop in to mail box no human
contact required it's that simple plus
you have five cents off every first
class stamp up to 40% off usps shipping
rates right now
stamps comm is also offering us UPS so
UPS services with discounts up to 62
percent and you're not gonna have to pay
UPS residential surcharges so this is
super easy right now my listeners got a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that is stamps comm
enter Shapiro stay safe in their stamps
calm and
Shapiro's alrighty we're gonna get to
Nancy Pelosi holding up small business
aid which is just insane
I mean truly it's crazy at this time
we're gonna get to that and we're gonna
get to present and Trump's plan to
reopen businesses what's right about it
what's wrong about it we'll get to that
in just one moment first it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily wire subscriber
today it's Cameron aka circle on
Instagram experiencing one of Wight's
greatest blessings in the midst of a
global pandemic in this picture Cameron
is holding a tiny baby swaddled up fast
asleep next to the world's greatest
beverage vessel the caption reads Peter
Thomas Turk born during this crazy time
is gonna make it through being nourished
by the plentiful supply of leftists
years hashtag leftist here's tumblr
hashtag daily where do not feed babies
tears guys you just go with the breast
milk it's fine amazing
you are already winning at the parenting
game thanks for the picture of that
that's it that's a that's a cute baby
that's a cute baby Congrats on the
growing family also being locked inside
right now
it requires double the excitement what
could be more exciting than a second
leftist yours tumblr
woohoo yes well right now when you
become a daily wire insider plus our
all-access member you get a second
leftist years tumblr I am not fitting
I'm not kidding with Bernie Sanders out
of the race for the presidency one
tumblr wasn't enough to hold all of the
tears head on over to daily wire calm
right now
daily where member it's got lots of
amazing benefits including of course the
magnificent the irreplaceable the
singular leftist cheers tumblr you also
get an ad-free website experience access
to all of our live broadcasts in show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now an exclusive election inside op-eds
from me daily where members also get to
ask us questions during backstage you
also get to participate in all excess
live that's our brand new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
wire host as we hang out with you each
night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific who is it tonight I don't even
know who it is tonight in any case we
have one of our hosts every night again
become an Insider plus all-access member
double your tears with two leftist years
tumblr head on over to daily wire.com
slash subscribe and get 10% off with
coupon code Shapiro so you get two
tumblers and 10% off with the coupon
codes Shapiro that is daily where calm
slash subscribed coupon code Shapiro
get the rarest of all beverage vessels
times two you're listening to the
largest fastest born conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so Nancy Pelosi has been holding up a
small business fund refill so the small
business fun ran out like immediately
because pretty much every small business
in America needs along every small
business in America has been forcibly
shut down by government and I saw some
libertarians over the weekend who are
sort of making the claim that it is anti
libertarian principle to take these
small business loans and as I have said
this is a taking okay according to
libertarian principle if the government
forces you to if the government were to
drive railroad through your backyard
they would have to compensate you for
that if the government were to drive a
railroad through your house they'd have
to compensate you for that the
government is driving a railroad right
through your business right now they
need to compensate you for that right
they shut down your business for public
purposes without just compensation to
take compensation for that is not anti
libertarian it is it is it makes perfect
sense the government imposed the cost
the government has to pay for the the
backside of all of that and if you don't
like it by the way vote out the
politicians if you want the government's
who not use it this sort of thing then
have different politicians okay well
right now the Paycheck protection
program is in limbo the Small Business
Administration said on Thursday it ran
out of money within like two weeks
millions of businesses unable to apply
for the loans while Congress struggled
to reach a deal to replenish the funds
Congress initially allocated 349 billion
dollars for the program that was
intended to provide loans to businesses
with 500 or fewer employees the money
went out quickly more than 1.4 million
loans approved as of Wednesday evening
they can't issue more loans until more
money has actually been put forth by
Congress naturally Democrats are holding
it up president Trump says we need more
funding these small businesses are
keeping people's paychecks going I mean
one of the conditions by the way of
actually taking a loan from the paycheck
protection program is that you have to
continue to pay your employees if you
don't continue to pay and it's 90
percent of your employees at 90 percent
of their salary or something like that
then you can't actually receive a loan
so people are getting the checks that
are allowing them to sustain themselves
during this time because of this program
here's from saying we need to refill the
fund we're negotiating with Democrats
and they should frankly approve it
quickly there's a great thing for our
country it's a great thing for small
business and for the workers and we're
having a hard time getting them to
approve it I think it's gonna happen
it should happen really unanimously but
they're trying to get things and we're
not too happy with what they
trying to get okay and that's exactly
right if you look at what the Democrats
are trying to dump into this program
according to The Wall Street Journal
Pelosi and Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
have called for further changes to the
program plus significantly increased
funding for disaster grants and loans
which is unrelated plus additional
support for food stamps which is
unrelated plus collection and
publication of demographic data so we
can accurately determine the level of
impact on underserved communities and
communities of color because it deeply
matters right now how we gather data on
racial differences by the way if you're
looking for correlative differences in
how this stuff is is affecting people
then there are two cross-cutting
factors that matter a hell of a lot more
than race poverty and pre-existing
conditions poverty pre-existing
conditions and age are the three things
that matter okay that I can tell you why
the Democrats are trying to break it
down this way because again they're
going back to the well the suggestion is
and they're making this suggestion
fairly obvious that if front mishandles
this thing that he has done so because
he is racist that is what they're going
to suggest they're going to suggest that
differentials and treatments are because
of underlying races and they did the
same exact bullcrap with george w bush
after hurricane katrina the suggestion
was not that that Bush just botched
Hurricane Katrina it's that he botched
Hurricane Katrina cuz he didn't care
enough for black people and they're
gonna do exactly the same thing here
they're setting up the groundwork for an
identity politics move here and it's
disgusting
it really is I'm fine with you gathering
any sort of data you want to gather but
if the implication is that America isn't
doing enough for black people because
they are black as opposed to black
people are dying at higher rates because
black people are more likely to be
suffering from pre-existing conditions
and if you want to connect that to
historic poverty you can try but some of
it has to do also with the fact that
eating habits matter that where you live
matters right like there are certain
there's certain factors that cross-cut
race and are much more correlative than
race itself Democrats are trying to boil
it down to race as they always do as the
Wall Street Journal says identity
politics and social pork-barrel Trump
jobs and business and business solvency
Nancy Pelosi was explaining why she was
rejecting small loans to businesses
while showing off twenty four thousand
dollar fridges in the background listen
I don't begrudge anybody owning a
$24,000 fridge Nancy Pelosi is a very
very wealthy person she was on with
James Corden and who is who's
broadcasting from home and again
owning expensive things you have a right
to do it I'm just wondering why it is
that Nancy Pelosi wants to prohibit
people from getting the loans they need
to sustain
businesses while she stands in front of
her fancy fridges pika Pelosi what have
you found what are you going to share
with us from your home chocolate really
chocolate chocolate candy oh wow
and this is this is something you can
get through the mail okay
run out and show me yeah absolutely this
is the episode of cribs I never knew I
needed oh wow
other people in our family beautiful
French nurse I'm offer the beautiful
French but I'm not gonna take him from
Nancy Pelosi when she says she doesn't
have enough data to back a refill the
small business funding she said that
also she was never enough data because
Democrats one thing we know about
Democrats they need data on how
government programs work before they
expend and before they extend them we
know this right like Head Start we need
if they had all the data they would just
extend that sucker or alternatively
Democrats are spend no matter what
because they assume the data don't
matter that throwing money at things
works except when the money is being
thrown at small business here's Nancy
Pelosi refusing to throw money at small
business at a time when government is
actively destroying small businesses we
again for support what we did with a PPP
but we want to make sure that when as it
gets more money it gets many more people
get access to the credit there have been
some questions asked about the money
baby committed but we haven't many of us
have not received it so that's all that
said back to a chairwoman that's saying
we want we want the data we want the
data yeah I'm sure you want the data I'm
sure it's just that you need rigorous
oversight of government spending this is
where Democrats are famous rigorous
oversight of government spending when
it's government wasting money on
absolute bullcrap stupidity then the
Democrats are like all in but when it
comes to we need to help businesses that
have been prohibited from doing business
then they're like up you know we need
the data we need it hard data right now
okay so all of this because businesses
are being shut down because people are
losing their jobs 22 million Americans
at atronics protests are breaking out
across the country we're seeing protests
in places like Michigan there's a
protest about 3,000 people in Lansing
Michigan people jamming the streets
around the State Capitol shouting that
they want things reopen in Frankfort
Kentucky dozens of people shouted
through a Capitol building wind
in Raleigh North Carolina one woman
who's arrested during a protest that
drew more than a hundred people now I
will say I think that protesting in
favor of reopening is not a bad thing
I think protesting in favor of reopening
while standing right next to each other
and breathing on them and sharing food
is a dumb thing I think it's a dumb
thing I think it's think it's dumb PR
like folks if you're gonna do protests
let me make a recommendation social
existence and wear masks during the
protest it takes away the baton the
media want to use against you the media
want to suggest that you are out there
protesting because you don't care about
the impacts of coronavirus and because
you don't mind if it spreads so why
don't you social existence during the
protest and tell the media yeah we don't
want to spread this thing but we need to
go back to work alright takes the baton
right out of their hands and the whole
hog rejection of sort of basic
scientific limits is very stupid PR at
least on that level but I certainly
understand the emotion that says we need
to open this thing up again so does
President Trump by the way so Trump
yesterday announced that he has a plan
for states to open relatively soon he's
doing this the right way he saying
states are in charge of how this program
works right states are going to
determine exactly how they reopen he
says some states could open relatively
soon and of course this is right not all
states are equivalent no state is New
York New York is New York no place else
is New York I think 29 states are in
that ballgame not open not for opening
but I think they'll be able to open
relatively soon I think the remainder
are just getting better look
New York New Jersey or having very tough
times and they'll be there they'll be
there at some point but they're not
going to be one of the earlier states
they're gonna be later obviously but we
have a lot of states that too location
through luck and also through a lot of
talent we have states through a lot of
talent they're in a very good position
and they're getting ready to open and
over the next verse short period of time
it's gonna be up to the governors that's
true and president Trump also laid out
what he said was his basic plan for
reopening yesterday so let's go through
these guidelines because I think there's
a lot here that's good and I think that
there's a lot here that is too
optimistic shall we say it's setting the
standards too high for reopening because
as I have said in a quick and dirty
fashion the reality is we're all gonna
end up like Sweden we're all gonna end
up saying to young people and two kids
and two adults who are healthy we are
gonna say to them go out live your
lives wear a mask socially distance and
that's about all we can do right and if
you're vulnerable and if you're elderly
then you should probably stay in until
treatments have been found
that's basically what Sweden has been
doing and you know what I'm not sure
that Sweden is wrong
in fact I'm fairly certain that Sweden
is probably correct okay so here are the
criteria that's been set out by the
White House so they have a proposed
phased approach based on up-to-date data
and readiness is from the White House
website white house.gov slash opening
America so they want to satisfy before
proceeding to phase two comeback a
downward trajectory of influenza like
illness is reported within a 14-day
period and a downward trajectory of
kovat like syndromic cases reported
within a 14-day period then one in
downward trajectory documented cases
from the 14 day period or a downward
trajectory of positive tests as a
percentage of total tests within a 14
day period so it declines every day for
14 days they want hospitals to be able
to treat all patients without crisis
care and robust testing programs in
place for at-risk health care workers
including emerging antibody testing okay
so here's the problem with this this is
actually kind of a problem the minute
that you release people from lockup the
minute you release people from lock-up
you'll see an uptick in cases you just
saw it in Singapore maybe setting up
ticking cases so does that break the
14-day downgrade so let's say you have
14 days where it's going down every day
day one you say to young people go back
out we're reopening the schools uptick
in cases does everybody go back in the
lockdown how does that actually work
okay the answer is it's not gonna be
able to work that way after there's the
14 day okay that's got to be a one-time
thing like okay we're getting this book
again what was the purpose of the
lockdown I was informed that the purpose
of the lockdown was to flatten the curve
so we didn't overwhelm our healthcare
system we've done that right we have not
overwhelmed their health care system
particularly every place outside of New
York there's no evidence that any place
outside of New York City has seen an
overwhelming of the health care system
where we haven't seen it even in the hot
spots like Detroit and New Orleans
there's really not been a lot of
evidence that people are going without
ventilators even in New York Bill
DeBlasio and Andrew Cuomo have said
there are not people who are waiting for
ventilators who can't convince waiters
right we've handled this thing and all
of the I am in the IH any studies that
you dub study right that study was
projecting hospital bed in ICU usage and
vents later usage far beyond what
actually materialized okay so if we have
flattened the curve below that point
then you have to assume that there will
be a second wave of infection
when you come back and that doesn't mean
you shut down again okay so that's
problem number one with this plan
okay so state and local officials
according to the White House may need to
tailor the application of these criteria
to local circumstances for example
metropolitan areas that have suffered
severe kovat outbreaks
additionally where appropriate
governor's should work on a regional
basis to satisfy these criteria okay
then course state preparedness
responsibilities ability to set up safe
and efficient screening and testing
sites for symptomatic individuals and
trace contacts of kovat plus results
okay so this is a problem problem number
one you want to set up efficient and
safe screening for symptomatic
individuals we know that asymptomatic
individuals are the people who actually
spread this the most so that's actually
not super helpful as I say I think the
standards here are too high I don't
think the standards are reachable I
think that if anybody ever a held
actually true to the whitehouse
standards no one reopens hover that's
one of the problems with the Whitehouse
standard so the left is saying these
standards are too loose I'm saying I'm
not even sure these standards are
practical in terms of reaching the
standard where you can reopen except in
rural areas where they're not bothering
to do any testing in fact this creates
an incentive not to do the testing
simply you so you can say that your area
is gonna reopen right you have to ensure
Sentinel surveillance sites are
screening for asymptomatic cases and
contacts for kovat plus results are
traced right so that means that you have
to you have to have asymptomatic
screening at places that serv older
individuals lower-income Americans
racial minorities Native Americans how
how are you going to do this you have to
have the ability to search ICU capacity
this is right
okay the ICU capacity and the
ventilators and the hospitals have to be
able to do what they need to do but
that's about all you can do and then
they have to have a plan for advising
citizens regarding protocols for social
distancing and all of the rest for
individuals they continue to say don't
touch your face wash your hands with
soap and water
especially after you touch frequently
used items or surfaces and discard
frequently used items as much as
possible if you feel sick you should
stay home but again that's not gonna
help cuz you're asymptomatic a lot of
the time there's thing that employers
should have temperature checks again I
don't know what the purpose of
temperature checks is everybody in my
office could have it right now I
wouldn't know they're asymptomatic like
we don't know especially among younger
people you're gonna need to to limit
business travel presumably to to sort of
essential business travel which of
course continues to kill the airlines
and then
phase one although unrolled all
vulnerable individuals should continue
to shelter in place
members of households with vulnerable
residents should be aware that by
returning to work they could carry the
virus back home precautions should be
taken to isolate from vulnerable
residents when in public you should
maximize physical distance right all of
that this part is fine
employers should continue to encourage
telework they should return to work in
phases they should close common areas
like kitchens minimize non-essential
travel all of that is fine specific
types of employers they're saying that
schools and organization
should remain closed visits to senior
living facilities and hospitals should
be prohibited large venues can operate
under strict physical distancing during
protocols that be sit-down dining moving
theaters sporting venues so they would
reopen restaurants but you'd have to
social existence you can go back to
church but you have to have like one
person per pew that sort of thing and
then they suggest that gyms could open
if they adhere to strict physical
distancing and sanitation protocols bars
from eight remember all of this is just
guidance for states states can still do
what they want States are still going to
be the chief actors here that's all
phase one phase two for states and
regions with no evidence of a rebound
all vulnerable individuals should
continue to shelter in place all
individuals should continue to should
maximize physical distance from each
other non-essential travel can resume
and then you continue to encourage
telework clothes common areas consider
special accommodations for personnel
members of a vulnerable population
schools and organized youth activities
can reopen visits to senior care
facilities and hospitals to continue to
be prohibited large venues still
continue that you can have elective
surgeries and gyms and bars that it
starts to be up and then finally phase
three is states and regions with no
evidence of a rebound and satisfy the
gating criteria a third time
finally vulnerable individuals can
resume public interactions employers can
resumed unrestricted staffing of work
sites visits to senior care facility so
my question is not what happens once you
get to phase two and phase three that
all looks fine my question is how you
even hit phase one right how are you
gonna hit phase one I mean bottom line
is that there's the they also suggest
that elderly individuals should
basically stay home throughout which
which is right in the end that's what's
gonna end up happening in the end what's
gonna end up happening is that if you
feel that you can take the risk you're
gonna go out and if you have parents who
are vulnerable you're not gonna see them
for a while that's what's gonna happen
your hope for treatment that develops
that's that's what this is going to end
up being for most
date any state that does not end up
doing that it's just a question of time
right New York is gonna say that they're
gonna take their sweet time about it
they're gonna end up in the same place
honestly if New York wanted to stop this
thing they should have shut down the
subways in the first place okay that
there's a study from MIT that suggests
that the subways were the chief
spreading mechanism which makes perfect
sense I've been suggesting that for
weeks okay but all over the country
there will be a reopening people are
hungry for the reopening and as we find
out from the antibody testing that I
think a multiple of the number of people
who supposedly have this thing have had
this thing people are going to feel that
the risk is worth undertaking if they
are young if they are healthy if they do
not feel that they are going to be
deeply affected as the treatments get
better so we're gonna see a gradual
reopening and I think the reopening is
gonna happen sooner rather than later I
think the White House response is
actually too restrictive in phase one
but I think once we hit the phases
that's basically how this is gonna roll
out okay so we've reached the end of
today's show we are out of time because
we have to go and do other things but we
have two additional hours of content
coming later today we also have a great
Sunday special coming up for you this
week we're gonna be talking to Scott
Gottlieb over at the former FDA
Commissioner about his plan for
reopening I'm gonna ask him questions
about testing I'm asking questions about
antibody testing how effective can all
of us be how fast can it be ramped up
I'll be talking with Steve Forbes about
the business side of this how exactly
does business survive how does business
undergo permanent change so you're gonna
want to check that out as well otherwise
head on over to daily wear now comment
and subscribe any level of membership
gets access to our awesome new features
including the the great all-access shows
that we are doing on a regular basis I
think we have a backstage next week also
a socially distance back they backstage
which we'll do next week so all sorts of
goodies otherwise have yourself a safe
and secure and excellent weekend I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel why
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 you know the
Matt Walsh oh it's not just another show
about about politics I think there are
enough of those already out there we
talk about culture because culture
drives politics and it drives everything
else so my main focus is our life family
faith those are fundamental and that's
what this show is about I hope you'll
give it a listen
you